today I'm going to share how to remove
skin tags in warts overnight now
sometimes they might take a couple days
to two weeks but you're going to notice
a significant shrinkage of the skin tag
a wart each time you apply this remedy
now this video is an updated video of
one that I did I think about a year ago
because I have something else to share
with you that is very very effective of
getting rid of the deeper cause so this
is new information I was debating
whether I was going to put this on a
YouTube video or not because they tend
to take these things down but I'm going
to try it out and see what happens but I
do have a lot more in-depth information
on my site but here's the big question
what is a skin tag and what is a wart
it's this growth on your skin that looks
like this little papule or pimple and it
doesn't necessarily keep growing it
might change in color but it is a benign
tumor a benign tumor is something that
doesn't turn into a malignant tumor
which is going to spread into cancer it
just kind of stays at a certain size but
the problem with these warts and skin
tags is sometimes especially the warts
can grow in your private parts I mean
vaginal area penis uh cervix rectum or
anywhere in the body they do tend to
grow in areas of folds in the body and
certain skin folds and they're kind of
an anabolic effect which means a
something that is growing that's what
anabolic means they are associated with
HPV which stands for human papiloma
virus
they're more common in women especially
when they're pregnant or if they have
polycystic ovarian syndrome or they
overweight now what's in common with all
three of these excessive amounts of
estrogen and it just so happens that
estrogen is anabolic it's an anabolic
hormone it's also more associated with
insulin resistance in diabetes Now what
is unique about this well people with
diabetes and insulin resistance
typically have excessive insulin but
people with diabetes usually have
insulin resistance which doesn't make
insulin work so even though they might
have more insulin at least at first they
actually are suffering from a deficiency
of insulin deeper in the cells but the
point is that insulin is an anabolic
hormone now let's talk a little bit more
about this HPV thing what is that well
HPV is not just one virus it's a strain
of 230 viruses some create more problems
for you than others but here's the thing
95% of the
population has HPV that means chances
are you likely have it in your body
right now and in fact
HPV causes at least 99% of the time I
think it's like 100% of the time
something called cervical cancer which
is the second most common cancer in
women and when I talk about cervical I'm
not talking about your neck I'm talking
about the cervix okay cancer in your
cervix is caused by HPV now how does the
HPV thing affect a skin tag or a wart
well it does a very specific thing to a
part of your immune system called the
natural killer cells so you have these
natural killer cells that are uh
designed to go after and kill cancer
cells as well as certain viruses and HPV
has an evil strategy of weakening
your natural killer cells your defense
against viruses and cancer but there's
some other things that also weaken this
NKC stress
injury trauma bereavement which is like
grief or loss of a loved one
surgery also a nutrient deficiency
especially low zinc and vitamin D in
fact people that have an active outbreak
of HPV are usually always deficient in
vitamin D and I think the reason for
that and this is just my guess is HPV
and other viruses have this other
strategy of blocking or downgrading your
vitamin D receptor weakening the
strength of your immune system so they
can exist and live and spread also
chronic inflammation can weaken the uh
the natural killer cells and aging as
well so even though 95% the population
has this virus why doesn't everyone have
skin tags in warts right and why do
certain women not all women get cervical
cancer well I think what happens is it
really depends on how much stress trauma
loss surgery how much vitamin deficiency
or or micronutrient deficiencies a
person has or how much inflammation they
have how old they are how much insulin
resistance they have so the greater
amount of those factors the more
likelyhood the person would would have
these skin tags warts let's talk about
what the remedy is okay and here's the
Simplicity of it you're going to take
one drop of iodine I recommend padone
iodine because padone is pretty safe
it's very cable very in expensive and
you put that in a little dish and then
we need to add some garlic so you can
either get a garlic Crusher or get a
couple spoons to crush the garlic or
press into it all you need is one clove
and then you take a Q-tip and I totally
spelled that wrong so forgive me on the
spelling but all you need to do is apply
something right over that skin tag or
wart then you put a Band-Aid right over
it okay and you're G to repeat this
every day until it's completely gone now
I'm GNA add one more thing and this is
going to be amazing uh because I found
something that's a super effective
remedy to clear out HPV I don't know of
any drug that can do it okay but this is
a natural remedy and it's called
ahcc and it stands for active hexos
correlated compound there's over a
hundred studies and the randomized
control trials okay this I think it's
mainly in Japan not in America I mean
this is highly researched and what it
does is it significantly increases the
potency of the natural killer cells it
reest establishes the strength of your
own body's immune system which is
awesome because there's virtually no
side effects and then that way your own
body can clear out this virus it also
strengthens the autonomic nervous system
both the sympathetic as well as the
parasympathetic so the combination of
the one drop of iodine and one drop of
garlic with ahcc I think it' be a
perfect uh REM
for not just making this go away but
really getting rid of the deeper root
cause as well as strengthening the
stress response so it can even
bulletproof you and strengthen your
immune system going forward now because
of the censoring and the suppressing of
the algorithms on YouTube it's becoming
more difficult to find my content and
there's a lot of content that I cannot
put on YouTube unfortunately so to make
sure you have full access of all my
information go to drberg.com And
subscribe to my newsletter by clicking
the link Down Below in the description I
will see you on the other
side